[Musique]
question diplôme je vois un brevet des
collèges
une formation coiffure question
expérience professionnelle miss nord pas
de calais waouh je viens pour la x pour
les jeunes familles on n'a pas les
moyens
ainsi d'acheter moins drogue ou six mois
des cachets oui on joue c'est nous qu'on
la paye le loyer
c'est donc un pas tort tu peux
comprendre ça tu peux commencer quand
[Musique]
celles offertes à temps de nettoyer la
machine ce soir voit pas sa trace en moi
ç'a toujours aucune classe est vraiment
canon disait tout moment ce projet
maintenant
[Musique]
les morts on a bien vu merci un problème
c'est qu'il faudrait sortir d'ici on
peut le sortir petit à petit bah quoi le
boulot de faire des boîtes gens me ou un
maquereau pareil non
[Musique]
jean-mi disparu que le pognon des belges
pourquoi tu l'auras pas dit pourquoi tu
veux qu'il fasse des frites avec
m'habite c'est quoi tu triches sait rien
dylan n'a trop confus faudra maintien du
don
[Musique]
car en plus de clous